foreign
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist a guy
with me Chuck Nice Chuck baby hey hey
Neil what's happening all right we're
doing Cosmic queries today yes yeah and
you collect them and I don't I don't and
and and we but we break we bring in an
expert yes to help it out yes and and
today we've got a friend and colleague
and a friend of StarTalk and a friend of
mine Matt Dowd Matt welcome back to
start talk great to be here again Neil
yeah your expertise is black holes
quasars gravitational lensing really
juicy tasty Cosmic things all of which
will kill you if you come in in the
vicinity of them immediately hostile
part of the cosmos exactly that's why we
love them uh you teach at Lehman College
of the City University of New York
that's right you're also an associate
here at the department of astrophysics
at the American Museum of natural
history and your host and writer for the
YouTube channel for PBS space time yeah
which has nearly 3 million subscribers
dude you're rocking it totally killing
it so you what is this film you were
part of this you got some other thing
you were inventing reality what is that
ah yes inventing reality oh it's called
U.S politics
exactly right yeah yeah this is a film
that we recently got crowdfunded and
we're in the process we love that okay
and what's it about it is about our
quest for the fundamental it's about
Humanity's search for the underlying
Clockwork of nature both from the point
of view of physics but also from the
point of view of Neuroscience brain
science so it's connecting how our
brains construct our models of the world
and and how that fact is connected to
how science at a societal level
constructs its models of the world and
you have a collaborator I do so uh
working with my partner bahara golipur
who is a neuroscientist we're writing it
together and it's being produced
with and directed by Andrew cornhaber
who's part of the space-time team okay
nice very nice so everyone should have
like a neuroscientist at Arm's Reach I
think 100 Gap I'm not alone I'm not
alone in that except I have to pay Mine
by the 45 minute
I but I do have one at Arm's Reach
so Chuck we've got questions which are
solicited from our patreon members
correct the threshold of access to this
feature is five dollars a month that's
it that's all it is that's it cup of
coffee all right so Matt are you ready
for us let's do it let's do it all right
all right by the way Matt and I have
overlapping uh expertise in the Venn
diagram so what will happen is that
whatever is right in his daily work
he'll take it but if it's something if
there's some spillage I I I'll jump in
too you okay with that Matt let's do it
together okay all right there you go
look look how man and and if the
spillage from that then Chuck can pick
up the slack right at that point we're
not looking at Spillers we're looking
more like at a environmental disaster
okay you know I mean that's kind of
excellent Valdez territory it's just
like and Chuck what do you think about
black holes we have reached a new low
okay here we go uh this is BSM
1989 says greetings Dr Tyson Chuck and
Dr Matt what my name is Blake and I'm
from Mobile Alabama can you elaborate on
energy density surrounding a black hole
and how Hawking radiation might work uh
is the material that falls into a black
hole loss forever and uh does it
eventually somehow get out
love it that's that's so that's all you
Matt take it well all right so this is
to answer this question I need to
summarize a large fraction of 20th
century physics
but we only have like I know I know I'm
gonna try
you're gonna start your answer by saying
first let me summarize 20th century
physics no no I'm serious because the
answer to your question is I was born
the son of a poor exactly
that's how I mean there's so much so
much of the story of the development of
20th century physics is around black
holes and this exact weird thing about
black holes that
what goes in seems to not come out and
this this is a paradox okay so all right
so first of all let's talk about a black
hole it is a uh place where gravity has
had its ultimate Victory so it's usually
the collapsed core of a star so you have
this hyperdense region where it is the
gravity is so strong that light can't
escape okay we don't know what's really
inside a black hole but there's this
region around you know whatever that
collapsed object is where you have uh
what we call the Event Horizon and
that's the distance from which light
can't escape that is black okay you uh
and so these things are invisible
um you know unless they're eating a star
or a Galaxy or something and then and
then we see the mess they make
um but
back in the 1960s Stephen Hawking
realized that black holes shouldn't
actually be completely black they should
radiate
um and this was Hawking's most famous
discovery called Hawking radiation and
uh you you it's described it a couple of
different ways one way is that you have
uh matter and antimatter particles
spontaneously appearing near the Event
Horizon normally they would vanish again
destroying each other but if one gets
sucked into the Event Horizon the other
can escape okay that's sort of the pop
side level
um Hawking Zone description of it was
talking about the positive and negative
frequency modes of the quantum vacuum
and how they get perturbed by the by the
black hole leaving the this this you
know the the vacuum itself generates
particles which you see okay so so
Hawking radiation uh causes black holes
to leak away their Mass so there's the
answer to the other part of the question
when something falls into a black hole
we think now so originally we thought
that that nothing could escape a black
hole because nothing can trouble faster
than light right but now I think most
physicists believe that because you have
this Hawking radiation what the at least
the energy that falls into a black hole
can eventually leak away uh as that
radiation and
the the really important thing about
that is that not only can the energy get
out but the information can get out and
this was what this was the other
perplexing thing about black holes
it shouldn't be possible to destroy what
we call Quantum information but via
Hawking radiation many physicists now
think that the the the details of what
you threw into the black hole somehow
get out via this walking radiation also
so they get remembered they get
remembered right yeah so it's almost
like
um whatever it is although it's not a
chair that went in
all of the things the blueprint
information on on that tiny tiny level
when it comes out that is still
available
yeah if you could if you could go to the
you know if you could collect all the
Hawking radiation that evaporated out of
a black hole over trillions of years
every little bit and somehow piece it
together the worst jigsaw puzzle in the
universe right you should be able to
reconstruct the chair and that's what
you guys say mean when you say
information you're talking about
all the stuff that we actually are on
that the inventory the part of the
inventory on the quantum all the way
down to the particles oh yeah the
information that you would need if you
wanted to rewind the universe and find
out what happened previously if you had
all the information then then in
principle you could you know run the
clock backwards and figure out what what
fell into the black hole in the first
place just to clarify a point you're
making you're saying it came out of the
black hole but in fact it came out of
the energy field in the vicinity of the
black hole which counts as coming out of
the black hole is that right thank you
for getting to the biggest hold in my
um in my argument here Hawking's
arguments were based on sort of internal
consistency arguments in that in that it
had to exist for the universe to make
sense but the actual mechanism of its
creation isn't clear we just know it has
to sort of emerge from the vicinity of
the black hole somehow with accounts for
having come out of the black hole
because it's using the gravitational
energy density created by the black hole
and it just happens to be outside of the
Event Horizon right yeah what so one one
description of how this happens is that
the thing that falls into the into the
black hole which is you know your your
anti-particle or your your negative
frequency mode or whatever somehow gains
negative mass or negative energy inside
the black hole
um because the the dimensions inside the
black hole get all twisted around and so
it's possible to have this this relative
negative Mass go inside which causes the
the positive mass of the black hole to
shrink a little bit wow
okay
no Chuck is that obvious that's
obviously
oh my God that is insane I love it wow
all right all right so cool here we go
hello Dr Tyson Dr O'Dell uh how do we
know black holes follow the second law
of Thermodynamics can black holes be
regions a fixed entropy
oh I like that because Matt you know we
say the second law of Thermodynamics in
a way that's an observed phenomenon
right there's no deep principle deeper
than it we just say up looks like
entropy increases everywhere so let's
make it a law and maybe the black hole
violates this this is such a good
follow-on question
um yeah I mean the crazy thing about
entropy is that it feels like it's
something that just you know emerges
from the way particles interact with
each other Etc but it also seems like
one of the most fundamental things in
physics because
no matter where you look entropy seems
to increase
um with a black hole
there is a way to think about its
entropy so we we think of entropy as a
measurement of the amount of disorder in
a system okay so a system will always
move towards states of more disorder
okay think about for example the air in
the room if you took all of the air and
compacted it down into you know a ball
this size it would first of all your
diet Association immediately but the air
would immediately burst out to fill the
room okay this
configuration where all the air
particles are in this one spot it would
be considered a very special or very
ordered configuration and so it would be
considered low entropy so the only thing
it can do from there is expand into a
more disordered Arrangement fill the
room that would be high entropy on in
the case of a black hole we can think of
their entropy as
uh in terms of information okay just
like we talked about so in the case of
the air in the room when the air fills
the room
we know
a lot less about the location of the
particles of the of the air molecules
okay so we have very little information
there's a lot more hidden information in
the air in the room when it's filling
the whole room
compared to if we have this ball of air
in our hands then we have a much better
idea of at least the location of all of
the particles they're all in this wall
of air okay so entropy can can be
considered as a measurement of the
amount of hidden information in a system
and over time
we tend to lose more and more of the
information of a system
so for a black hole
as a black hole grows it's swallowing
things from the external universe and
because
we can't get information about what fell
into a black hole out very easily as a
black hole grows its entropy increases
okay so the amount of hidden information
increases and so there's this very tight
relationship between actually the
surface area of a black hole and the
amount of stuff that it's eaten which
corresponds to the amount of information
that that black hole is hiding and so I
won't get into the next point but I
gotta mention it was this simple
observation that the entropy of a black
hole is proportional to its surface area
that led us directly to the holographic
principle the notion that the
information of the interior of a volume
can be completely encoded on the surface
of that volume and it led people like
Leonard suskin and others to realize
that you could actually encode the
interior of the Universe on its surface
area uh and that's another story that
that led directly from this notion of
black hole entropy
interesting
okay so we're all two-dimensional
Holograms that's the Takeaway on this
that's the takeaway
there's a real answer Chuck I always
knew you were just a two-dimensional
person you know what you what you meant
was uh that uh yeah that I thought you
meant my character
okay not my physicality all right right
all right give me another one sure that
was cool so by the way I don't know if I
said that that was deep and dust that
was uh the the person Dipping Dots deep
in DOS oh deep in DOS okay okay
and uh this is
anthropoc Dylan
I like it yeah very cool uh hello Dr
Tyson Dr Dow Dr comedy in space
documentaries like PBS space-time they
talk about future Cosmic events in
distant galaxies on Earth timelines
instead of saying the sun will blow up
at 5 billion years from the perspective
of a galaxy far away how do you adjust
for the time dilation so that the
information you're talking about is
correct in the instant in terms of
Relativity it seems like Galactic
simulations sort of Step through a
wormhole to film ex solar systems
or that should be exosolar because so in
other words what what uh what is the
rate at which time ticks on things we're
observing and if it's not ticking at the
same rate that they were ticking here on
Earth who are we to put it on our
timeline
why don't we pick that up when we return
in segment 2 on Star Talk Cosmic queries
weird wacky stuff that our guests Matt
or Dowd is an expert in when start talk
returns
we're back start talk past Aquarius yes
got chuck with me Chuck you still there
yeah I'm still hanging with us man this
is deep stuff coming down here Matt oh
dab friend and colleague uh from Lehman
College of the City University of New
York so uh your expert in in this
session we've got you in for like
quasars and black holes and and and
weird wacky fun things that will kill
you post haste
in the universe so what else you got so
what we were talking about before the
break was from uh anthropo Cosmic Dylan
who uh is actually Dylan from San Diego
in the short what he was talking about
it seems like Galactic simulations kind
of stepped through a wormhole to film
extrasolar systems EXO solar systems
because you know they're they're not
really on our timeline but we put them
on our timeline so what's what's the
deal what's up with that I mean yeah how
do we reckon the relativistic effects uh
time dilation in an expanding Universe
on a timeline that we're just trying to
set up for the universe here on Earth uh
shall I take a shot at this deal or yeah
please yeah let me do it I just asked
you I actually I don't want to answer
all right all right I'm leaving right
for you so the stuff that I study is far
enough away that this matters
um many of you have heard that the
universe is expanding which means that
at a distant galaxies appear to be
moving away from us and you look far
enough away they're moving away from us
at a big fraction of the speed of light
okay and so Einstein showed us that the
rate at which your clock ticks depends
on your motion and the rates that you
see a clock ticking depends on the
motion of that clock relative to you
okay so fast moving objects you see that
their clock appears to be ticking slower
right and so
I for example study quasars in a very
distant universe and we really have to
take this into account okay so we might
see these quasars fluctuating okay these
are supermassive black holes that are
you know each seeing a bunch of gas from
their Galaxy and they're they're pretty
chaotic they they splutter and they
split
um over time uh super interesting to
study that variability but if you're
looking at something that's half a
universe away then this thing called
relativistic time dilation slows down
their sputtering and spurting
dramatically and so you have to
remember that and put that fact into
your calculation otherwise you get it
all wrong oh okay so you do Factor it in
if you actually make the adjustment you
make the adjustment right unfortunately
fortunately it's a it's simple algebra
Einstein made that one easy for us right
right yeah I have um my one paper that
is co-authored with a Nobel Laureate uh
I'm the last author on that paper it's I
think it was the first measurement of
time dilation in a supernova light curve
because you have Supernova in the outer
Universe we have predictions of how
quickly they'll brighten and how slowly
they will dim and so we know what they
look like nearby and out in the universe
it was taking longer for that to happen
so we can say is this a different kind
of supernova or you plug in the
expansion rate of the universe for its
distance and bada bing it comes out
right right as you expect it
so yeah it wasn't actually happening
slower it was a time dilation effect so
this is this was profound yeah that is
very cool by the way um you don't have
to uh qualify being the last author on a
Nobel Laureate paper you could just be
an author on the paper okay okay okay
that's enough
all right here we go this is Cameron oh
by the way so so that the lead author
was Brian Schmidt who won the one the uh
Nobel prize for the discovery of dark
energy
which was empowered by measurements such
as these with supernovae so and he's a
noise
and I'll tell you now I think isn't that
right yeah
yeah for a long time he I mean he was
born in the U.S so I think that he's
been uh yeah he's down under you're the
longest one all right Chuck give me more
moving on to Brendan gabasi and Brenton
says hey this is Brenton from Lansing
Michigan and uh
is it possible for a black hole of any
size to be a quasar given it has enough
matter around it to heat up and how
close would a quasar have to be to the
Milky Way in order for us to just see it
in the evening sky and if it's not too
much to ask can you elaborate on the
news that is quickly spreading about the
hole that's 20 times the size of Earth
in the sun I mean I don't think that's
related to a black hole because RC could
never be he's got anxiety
Joe yeah tell me about hey man should I
worry about the hole in the sun
there's a Black Hole Sun please
it's a question about holes that's all
it is right yeah it is questionable
holes nice job once you take your son
one first do you know do you know the
sun one no I you know I I'm tempted to
shift screen and Google that right now
but that would be cheating is it a
sunspot Maybe yeah like sunspots are you
know ordinary sunspots are about the
size of the Earth yeah but the sun can
have storms and explosions that are way
bigger and we are approaching a solar
maximum in in terms of Magnetic storms
right that's in 2025 I think right it's
on the upswing you know why I saw the
Northern Lights from right here on this
deck a few weeks ago the first time in
my life
look at that and this is New York state
Robert you saw Aurora uh yeah I saw that
I saw in Aurora you know it was faint
and it was you know it but it filled the
Horizon and you know you could see the
curtains shifting very slowly
or just the colors it has to be once my
yeah once our eyes had really adapted we
could we could see a little bit and
what's your location now on Earth
far away from City Lights yeah exactly
yeah so so that wasn't just the Empire
State Building changing its College
oh damn because the Yankees won or
something okay just checking so anyway
and it's 20 times they say the size of
the Earth but then when you think about
it how many Earths can you fit inside
the Sun a million 110 in diameter what a
million in volume but yeah yeah yeah 100
across times a cubed is a million right
right so you could put a Million Suns
inside the entire ball a million Earths
a million I'm sorry a million Earths
inside the buyer the ball that is the
Sun but you would see uh uh what you say
a hundred Earths going straight across
yeah about that but I'm saying I'm
saying you know if the sun can hold a
million Earths what are you worried
about for a whole 20 exactly for 20 yeah
20 times the size big deal
20 that's 20 of the diameter that's not
a small hole
Let's uh yeah okay
shining still exactly
no if it's a whole it wouldn't be 20 of
the diameter it'd be the square root of
that right
[Laughter]
I would say chuck could you back me up
here Chuck come on
if you look at a hole that's 20 times
the size of Earth it's not 20 across
you're right if if that statement was
about the projected
the area Okay context matters all right
there we go I think we have another part
of this question that I actually have
some expertise yeah let's do it yeah so
the rest of it can you have quasars that
are small like you know you can have
relatively small black holes can they
become quasars in the right
circumstances well sort of
so uh any size any decent sized black
hole can form what we call an accretion
disc around it so if you get gas close
enough the gas will form this Whirlpool
material that's that's swirling into the
black hole the whirlpool will heat up
and it's from that heat glow that you
get the super bright Quasar now a quasar
and the related what we call Active
Galactic nuclei are when you have a
black hole in the center of a galaxy and
and they're big but there are smaller
black holes what we call Stellar Mass
black holes that are left over after a
massive star dies and these might be you
know 10 times the mass of the Sun you
know up to you know several tens times
the mass of the Sun and these things
conform what look like mini quasars but
it's in a very special circumstance and
that's when that black hole happens to
fall into a binary orbit or to have
formed in the binary orbit with another
star okay those if if those stars get
too close then the envelope of the
living star can spill over into the
influence of the black hole and
that's definitely what it's doing uh
sucking its life out and then so you get
an accretion just it's relatively small
compared to you know a quasar but it's
still you know solar system size it's
still big and these are called x-ray
binaries because we first saw them from
the bright x-ray light that they emit
um and and these we see through the
universe even in the Milky Way the
nearest one is the um the cygnus
X1 black hole which is about a thousand
light years away okay so uh so we do get
many questions these are basically
nearby baby quasars in a sense well baby
except they're not going to grow up to
be adult quests
wait so Matt where's the threshold what
would you say is a threshold between
just an active Galactic nucleus and what
we officially would label as a quasar
yeah it's a you know the definitions are
muddy because these things are very far
away
and they they all all these active
Galactic nuclei look a bit different
depending on you know how much gas is
going in how big the black hole is even
what is the orientation of the accretion
disk uh at some angles we don't even see
it because there's a bunch of Gunk
surrounding it that blocks it so there
could be galaxies that are quasars for
some parts of the universe and not for
others yeah absolutely yeah okay that's
interesting so it's an orientation thing
yeah exactly um but the threshold for a
quasar it's essentially a very luminous
active Galactic nucleus that we in which
we can see the accretion disk right so
you have to you have these two
parameters the the Luminosity which is
partially driven by the Black Hole Mass
okay bigger Black Hole Mass can support
a bigger disc
right it's complicated
Now Matt what I heard is it's still true
because it's been a while since I've
looked at this that the reason why
quasars are all far away is because
nearby galaxies that may have once been
quasars ate all of their gas they
completely consumed their accretion disk
so there's nothing left to right belly
they've eaten it is this a fair is that
because the quasars at the edge of the
universe that's long ago yeah and far
away yeah galaxy far far away the nearby
Galaxies have done lived their early
lives none eaten there and so they're we
don't have a prevalence of quasars
nearby is that understanding Still Still
accurate so the short answer is you're
totally right the longer answer is
you're partially right and there's
another effect so it's true that that
the Universe went through something that
we call the Quasar Epoch yeah which was
like you know ended a few billion years
ago uh and and the quasars so there's
this kind of middle period of of the
universe's life where the quasars flared
up being the biggest galaxies that exist
in the universe and that basically
corresponded to when those galaxies were
being built okay so as you know the Big
Bang happened galaxies started being
built so there was a supply of food
supply of food for the biggest galaxies
which had the biggest black holes
nowadays those galaxies are basically
done being built and more of the Galaxy
building action is for the lower Mass
galaxies like you know some spiral
galaxies a bit more like the Milky Way
and these things don't tend to create
big quasars but the other the other
effect is that you know Quasar like
full-blown quasars aren't that common in
the universe and so we don't
you know we don't even have
a Galaxy that would have been one very
close to us right
so no no you say they're not that uh
prevalent
um or
um common in the universe uh
could there still be a lot more that we
haven't seen just because how many how
much of the night sky have we actually
seen
you know what I mean uh that can you or
does it work out that what we have seen
you can extrapolate and say that we're
going to see that exact amount if we
were to see everything
yeah I mean I think you answer the
question trucks are things uh but but
yeah we've seen a lot of the universe
our surveys have scanned a huge volume
of the universe it's hard it's hard to
look directly through the disk of the
Milky Way because there's too much stuff
in the way but but above and below we've
seen a lot and we've found many hundreds
of thousands of quasars there okay so I
say they're not common but the universe
is big but we see them okay big universe
rare things are common
or abundant or something yeah yeah
it makes perfect sense it makes perfect
sense right right it makes it it just
makes perfect sense
simpler than that all right this is
Cameron Bellamy who says greetings from
Baltimore if one in a million people is
seven feet tall then in a country or 300
million people they're 307 foot taller
so you still might not get on the
basketball team yeah the The Big Numbers
bail you out of that
right exactly yeah and of course what's
the adjective we have for big numbers
they would be
astronomical yes
we kind of corner The Big Numbers yeah
we totally own the big number yeah
that's you guys yeah we got all the big
numbers
all right give me another one this is
Cameron Bellamy he says greetings from
Baltimore Maryland on this show Neil has
talked about the consequences of our
expanding universe and it's eventual big
rip I'm curious how this phenomenon will
affect black holes from my understanding
black holes are super dense matter and
space-time expands will the Super dense
black holes become less dense until
eventually representing matter density
similar to what the rest of the universe
has and thereby being able to be ripped
will the opportunity for Life arise from
what was once a black hole as the
universe expands in the far distant
future my boy's thinking about this let
me tell you this oh question he should
have he should have followed up with and
it only took me one year to think of
this question
we're going to pick up the answer to
that at the beginning of segment three
right after this break
we're back Cosmic queries based on the
expertise of my friend and colleague
Matt O'Dowd who teaches at Lehman
College of the City University of New
York and Matt how do we find you on
social media beyond your YouTube channel
which has three million followers yeah
so you could go to to PBS space time and
and just watch me talk about space and
quantum mechanics and everything I've
seen episode Theory great you're totally
there friendly and I mean it's normative
and I always want more when I see it so
congratulations on what you've created
there and it's a part of the PBS
Universe I guess right yeah yeah it's a
PBS show
um okay uh PBS digital Studios to be
precise nice uh you know otherwise I am
Matt of Earth underscores uh on Twitter
and on Instagram Matt of Matt of Earth
of Earth Earth this is Earth's mat
yeah okay Morris has his own mat just in
case people are wondering Chucky's
getting ready for the aliens there you
go exactly
if they come here
and they say take us to your mat we will
know we will know we want to go to the
mat on this one Hey where's Matt then
we'll know yeah of course everybody
knows Matt of Earth that's why we're
here
all right we're picking up where we left
off uh we had Cameron Bellamy who
basically was saying when you look at
the big rip and you consider black will
it affect black holes yeah calls and and
does it affect them differently because
they're such they're so dense yeah what
do you know about that Matt yeah so this
this is pretty speculative but I'm gonna
take my best guess so the Big Rip is
probably probably not going to happen it
only happens if dark energy is something
more exotic than most physicists think
it is if if the strength of dark energy
increases over time then
eventually the accelerating expansion of
the universe can affect smaller and
smaller regions eventually subatomic
scales tearing everything apart right
okay so if that's the case then
it would affect black holes I think
because black holes contain space and
that's if that space contains a
an increasing amount of dark energy that
dark energy has an anti-gravitational
effect
um I think what it would do would be
would be to cause black holes to
evaporate more quickly quickly that
would that would be my guess so black
holes are evaporating as we learn by
Hawking radiation my guess so the event
Horizons shrinking so my guess is that a
big rip style Dark Energy would would
cause that that evaporation down so my
guess I like to hear what you said there
my guess is that the opposite will
happen is that they'll evaporate less
quickly because the expansion dilutes
the energy density in their environment
around the round around them and which
will make it less likely to produce the
particles however what you said was
seems to be all in where the black hole
volume is made of space-time like
anything outside the volume and it's
space time that's getting stretched yeah
so I can imagine the Big Rip simply all
unzipping black holes right right and
because it's stretching them out so that
they don't no longer have their black
hole
um Event Horizon density
yeah I I bet someone has calculated this
yeah so I haven't I haven't calculated
and but but some combination of our two
answers sound like it's gonna be it now
let's get back real quick because I know
we don't have a lot of time left in the
show because we got to get to more
questions good please go back to
um why the Big Rip is not going to
happen because you're the first look let
me it will happen if the strength of
this dark energy grows relative to
gravity as the universe expands oh it
will happen What Matt was saying is
we're not entirely sure that dark energy
will grow in strengths as the universe
expands relative is that did I
characterize you correctly yeah the the
default
model for dark energy is that it
maintains a constant intensity okay I
got you now I'm totally straight now
okay great okay that's awesome all right
let's go
to our friend
alejandroso
okay
I have to assume he's not offended by
this Chuck because otherwise we would
have gotten mail from him by now we have
not uh it doesn't matter we have not
received any uh cease and desist orders
from Alejandro
uh so
alejandroso says
this is Alejandro Reynoso from Monterrey
Mexico and he says
hello okay what should I say hola
how do you use gravitational lensing in
your observations it is absolutely does
it actually let you see distant objects
clearly or do you need to make many
adjustments to come up with your image
so how are you utilizing gravitational
lensing yeah man Matt what does your
object look like after it's been
gravitationally lensed
great I love this question because I
know I know about it um
[Laughter]
Einstein guy again have predicted that
gravitational fields bend the parts of
the path of light you know bend the
fabric of space-time and so uh you look
out there in the universe and you see
that distant objects aren't necessarily
where they appear to be particularly if
there's something big like a whole
galaxy between you and that object and
the things that I that I'm interested in
are gravitationally lensed quasars there
we go quasars again where you have a
distant quasar
an intervening Galaxy and you just
happen to be perfectly lined up so that
the light from that distant Quasar is
deflected by the gravitational field
and comes back towards us and so we
actually see the same Quasar through
multiple paths through space we get
light from multiple different parts of
space so what it looks like is multiple
images sometimes just two images of the
same Quasar sometimes four so you
actually looks like you see two images
or four Images but really there's always
an odd number of images and that's
because in between the two images or the
four Images there's a tiny little image
of the original objects normally you
can't see that because you've got this
great big Galaxy or whatever is doing
the lensing in the way
um but yeah fun fact you always get an
odd number of images with gravitational
lensing so my interest is in trying to
use gravitational lensing to
probe the infrastructure of those
quasars so you have this giant accretion
disk around the black hole but really
these things are so far away that
there's no telescope that we can even
imagine building that'll be able to take
a real picture of a quasar and and see
that in a structure but in the case of
gravitational lensing
you can
basically reconstruct what the Quasar
looks like because you have one more
effect at play so the lens if it's a
galaxy is it's a pretty crappy lens It's
Made of Stars and because everything in
the universe is moving relative to each
other you see occasionally you'll get
this extra special alignment of a star
inside the lensing Galaxy with one of
these one of these Pathways so one of
these Pathways might pass in the
gravitational field of an individual
star with such an alignment that it that
that one image grows in brightness and
then shrinks again and so over time you
see these you know let's say there are
four Images you see them flicker on
different time scales and from that
flickering you can actually reconstruct
the inner structure of the Quasar
because the the rate of the flickering
depends on on how big the Quasar is and
so you can sort of map it out in this
way
and I I remember I was active in
graduate school when this first
measurement was made where someone
looked at one of the lensed quasars and
and it flared in some way and then they
waited for the other image to flare yeah
and it's exactly the same way and that's
crazy and delay right because the path
length difference between One Direction
around the object and the other I mean
it was a brilliant thing everyone was
sitting around waiting for it and bada
bing there it is that is really cool and
you know that's why you knew it was the
same okay it had to be the same it was
just on a delay
[Applause]
same way this is so cool because
initially you don't know what it is this
an object in the image right and so I
was in graduate school when that
happened that's how old I am Matt I'm
like decades older than you so uh I'm
remembering this stuff not too many I
didn't think well you know you know this
that that that exact thing like
measuring the different path links is
going to be one of the ways that we
actually figure out what dark energy is
because if you can measure those
different path links you can get the
distances to the to the lens to the to
the Quasar and so you can actually
match the expansion history of the
universe by getting those distances and
that's one of the ways we might be able
to whoa to figure out the rate at which
the universe is right because oh my God
that's it because the universe is
actually not just expanding at a
constant rate it's speeding up so when
you're able to get those distances and
see the differences on the delay you can
actually kind of calculate the dark
energy because that's what's behind it
right exactly yeah damn yep
wow okay okay that's amazing no but we
still there's still people walking Among
Us I don't have science
if that doesn't get you nothing will
that is some amazing stuff right there
all right here we go this is Renee Renee
Renee says hey guys I just heard about
the red star uh actress and that I could
have a planet or sub Stellar object
orbiting it 12 times larger than Jupiter
about a month ago you had a Gaston that
said Jupiter was the largest planet ever
discovered so what do you think could be
orbiting can't wait to hear the answer
thanks from Orange County California
Renee okay I don't know that we had a
guest that said Jupiter was the largest
planet ever because it's definitely not
all right plenty of other planets in the
exoplanet catalog are bigger than
Jupiter the difference is if you start
getting much bigger than Jupiter we
don't really call them planets anymore
right I mean they're like brown dwarfs
we have other vocabulary for them so
that's really what's going on here
failed story Matt do you have any
insight into that question yeah I'm not
aware of this result but ten times
larger 12 times larger than Jupiter is
really getting on the verge of
the smallest star level well 100 so it's
a brown block so the question is is it a
planet or is it a failed star and I
think the answer is it depends on how it
Formed you know if if if they if the two
form together by you know collapsing
from the same giant cloud of gas and
finding each other then it's a binary
star system one of them is just a failed
star but if the big star forms first and
then this giant Jupiter formed in the
disk of leftovers around that star then
you might call it a giant planet yeah so
the origin story matters yeah origin
story matters it sounds like it makes
sense so one's cleaning up stuff yeah
exactly and the other one is out of the
same out of the same right right wow
okay cool man you know that that was a
cool question uh Renee thanks
um
here we go Trisha Lynch says hello and
greetings from Beaverton Oregon my
question is what would happen if
galaxies stop rotating what what
happened
um
on this one you ready so if the Milky
Way stopped rotating today
then every single star
would fall to the center yeah because
it's orbital speed that's maintaining
our distance without that orbital speed
they will fall to the center and Matt
what do you have waiting for everybody
at the center behind door number one man
my favorite Cosmic friend the
supermassive black hole there you go
four Million Suns worth of black hole
and if they really stop perfectly then
technically everything would well yeah
it would be a mess it would be a mess it
would go straight to that black hole
four million would be billions of times
yeah is the black hole exactly in the
center oh okay I'm not sure I'm not sure
so they might they might they might do
close you know everything would would
end up in these I don't know if it's
exactly in the center good question
we'll see things but there'd be
collisions yeah it would be bad yeah all
right and and the whole galaxy could
just be eaten by the black hole at that
point that would be interesting wow all
right yeah that's that's maybe something
Thanos would do yep would be just yeah
don't you don't like me you have to snap
a finger he actually claps like
like The Clapper that turns the lights
off you're like and then everything just
falls to the super massive black hole in
the center of the Galaxy or the
choreographer on Broadway
step up to the day
yeah that would be that's how to destroy
a Galaxy on the spot and make up super
massive super duper massive black hole
says Hey greetings from Brooklyn New
York am I kidnapper
that's right and we haven't been he and
who are fans my kid and I are fans of
the show and we have uh been to the
Hayden planetarium at least a dozen
times so my question for Matthew Neal
and hello Chuck uh yeah he ain't asking
me anything
okay
it says why is solar gravitational lens
Mission hasn't happened yet and when is
it likely one of the most powerful tools
to study exoplanets and find life
besides our local Sample When will that
happen
the lensing that bonan pachinski was
doing the um micro lensing do you think
that's what he's talking about there now
this is a plan to um
send out a
little
telescope to
a point in the art of solar system so
there's a point in way out Beyond
uh you know Neptune uh I was gonna say
Pluto then I realized you were here yeah
yeah that's right wavy on Neptune and so
there's this point where uh and so
you've got the sun the sun is a big
gravitational object it bends the path
of light and there's this region
um kind of how far away it is it's like
a you know a weak white travel time away
or something like that where light from
a distant object will come to a focus
due to the sun's gravitational appeal
and if you could put a telescope in this
basically this focal I remember this
Telescope yes yeah yeah yeah this this
this this sort of that you know and it
extends over a certain range because it
depends on how far away the the um the
the object is but if you put a telescope
there then then the sun would become an
extra lens on that telescope and it
would produce such powerful
magnification that you could see
so the calculations go a a single planet
orbiting around a distant star which is
something that is extremely difficult
for us I remember this but then it's I
didn't then I stopped reading about it
so is this idea going away no it hasn't
gone away you know people have been
thinking about it for a long time and
are still
like I I hear people talking about it
and and
isn't the sun in the way how are we
going to see a lensed planet when the
sun is brighter than everything it's
like trying to find a firefly in a in a
Hollywood Searchlight how how does this
actually work I I agree and I see where
you get the magnification effect that
would be amazing I get that but there's
still the matter of this I guess you
have to have some kind of like a uh some
kind of disc that blocks the sunlight in
the telescope you'd have to have
something like that yeah I I love it
when you ask me a question and then
answer it perfectly uh so I mean you
know just picking it up on the Fly you
know you know I'm sure you know about
Corona graphs we call them yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you would
and there are ideas about how you would
build these giant Corona grass basically
a big
Circle but they're also various
interesting complex
things that would unfurl in front of
this uh this distant telescope that
would block the Sun's light and so you
could see this you know basically this
ring so so what what it would look like
would be
the Sun blotted out but then surrounding
the sun this perfect ring what we call
an Einstein ring and that that that
perfect ring would be the exoplanet okay
so if it were another you know another
civilization doing this for the Earth
they would use their star to look at the
Earth if they were if they just happen
to be in the right position to do that
and then Earth's structure would be
smeared around but to the level that if
you reconstruct it and You Could
reconstruct it just by you know using
good old
Einstein general relativity to to to
figure out what the image looked like
you know uh and so anybody could do it
right yeah anybody could literally
literally anybody you could you could
see you know Continental coastlines down
to I can't remember the exact scale but
you know kilometers or something like
that so you could literally map the
surface of that distance but you'd have
to reconstruct the sphere from the
smeared Circle exactly right the visual
image from that right so that'd be a
whatever task that would be okay I
forgot all about that telescope right
Matt thanks for reminding me I got to
tell you the truth it sounds like the
worst camera ever
it really does I don't want to be a
hater but I'm just saying Chuck Hayden
on the most advanced system
no I'm joking so Matt we got to call it
we got to call it quits there man that
went fast sounds good all right I'm sad
but but you know what let me give you
one quick one because this guy is
personal and professional this question
it's a personal professional question
this is David Lee's or lays and he says
hello Dr O'Dell uh have there been any
surprise findings in your research that
have shaken up your understanding of
astrophysics
in my personal research in your personal
research I wish uh in my personal
research have I
shaken up the understanding of my oh man
now now I'm gonna get sad because I I
don't think I have personally
revolutionized my own understanding um
you know there there have been things
that have surprised me there's been
objects that I've studied that have
surprised the hell out of me
gravitational lenses that have done
things that I really didn't expect them
to uh I managed to I have managed to
find ways to look at the Interiors of
quasars that that that are relatively
new and found thousand things like like
so it's not a new object it's a new
tactic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you take
it a little bit hard on yourself but I
know right man you're a little harder
than yourself yeah there's some weird
stuff out there and for everybody
listening you just found out the heart
of every scientist right there in that
question and answer because scientists
what they don't want to do is succeed
what they want to do is look down and go
what the f is that what
oh my God come over here
that's to that's what gets scientists
all free that's how it works yeah it's
not it's not to discover what you know
right finding something you have no idea
what the hell you're looking at right
all right dudes we gotta call it quits
there so thank you for yet another
episode of Star Talk Cosmic queries Neil
deGrasse Tyson here as always bidding
you
looking up
[Music]